before we bring in Tom Verducci from
Sports Illustrated and of course worked
the game last night for Fox
here's Clayton Kershaw this past Friday
where I talked to him about the
baseball's people are saying the ball
deduced you know all baseball season and
I'll be the first to jump on that
bandwagon because I've given up a ton of
homers so I you know I'm all in on that
philosophy but you know at the end of
the day I always say it's like well
everybody else is dealing with it too
right it's not like it's not like I'm
the only one giving up a lot more homers
so I don't really care
homers are cool people like seeing them
so if they're doing something sneaky
here behind our back economy I don't
really care he might feel differently
today after last night he's now given up
eight home runs in the postseason most
ever by a pitcher we bring in Tom
Verducci Sports Illustrated Major League
Baseball on Fox
Tom you wrote a column where you're
talking about these baseball's summarize
the column and what kind of impact has
that had on this World Series in your
opinion yeah 2015 last two months of the
season that the ball is alive the air
forever reason but the issues now here
the World Series Dan is that the
pitchers and pitching coaches from both
teams are telling me that this ball the
World Series ball is slicker than the
regular season ball and they're having a
hard time getting a good grip on the
ball especially when it comes to
breaking off sliders and I think you saw
it again last night with curse' he threw
39 flutters last night and had one swing
in this the fewest he's had and like a
hundred and thirty four starts hmm and
he just couldn't get that thing to move
it way it normally does and I asked him
about it after the game and he kind of
gave a wry grin and he shrugged his
shoulders and he said well I guess it's
the same for both teams
so you know whether there's something
going on with the ball or not I don't
know but I do know this these guys have
the baseball in their hands all the time
you know any alterations to the ball
these pitchers and pitching coaches it's
their business to know it
but and I noticed Darvish I know Kershaw
like the ball seemed flatter there
wasn't as much movement there I know
both staffs are dealing with it do you
think baseball have you asked baseball
if they they wanted this this was
intentional no I don't think they wanted
this my own theory on the ball in
general over the last couple of years is
that there has always been a window of
what the performance of the ball is both
in terms of size weight and how lively
the ball is you know there's some leeway
here margin of error if you will well I
think the technology the manufacturing
has gotten so good they can manufacture
these balls closer to the narrow and
double liveliness or maybe the higher
end if you will does more lively ball to
tighter ball the scenes are lower you
get lower seam you're gonna have less
drag let's drag you out and the more the
ball is going to carry so yeah wasn't
that long ago is only in 2014 you're
talking about a real downturn in offense
of the game you're headed toward 1968 I
mean it was the worst offensive period
since the BH was established in 73 and
we made a u-turn and there's never been
a period in baseball history we're home
run and run scored went up as quickly as
this did without some obvious reasons no
the past it was always maybe got in the
back war or you had the th or you had a
live clear ball back in the 20s we don't
have any of those things to play here
other than the ball itself and the
questions people have about it if I
didn't see the game last night how would
you sum it up action flick you know you
go see an action movie for the first
time and it's like a million these cars
are crashing there's monsters and like I
gotta go back and see that thing again
and figure out what actually happened in
order to talk about the players about
that after the game like what was your
favorite part of what we remember and
let me tell you something after that
game that says spent as I've seen a
clubhouse that was the winning team the
Astros I'm talking about mentally
physically the brains were shot from
that game it was really a fun ride you
know I know it's a long game but people
who stuck through it really got rewarded
because I I thought the action was
really good I mean those guys on base
the lure balls flying out of the
ballpark and awful
entertaining it reminded me of the movie
Mad Max there was just so much involved
in Mad Max I don't know if it was but
see with Mad Max I didn't know if it was
a great movie or not I knew that was a
great game last night but I did have to
go back and watch Mad Max again I I was
just fascinated with big moments
although kershaun Keuchel didn't step up
the heaters did step up in big moments
there who's your MVP so far at this
point oh wow that's a great question
I got a top-floor there I mean I love
what Bregman has done this whole series
especially defensively in his big
moments but last night to me I mean if
you're talking one moment or sequencing
the game how about Brandon Morrow comes
in for the 12th time in 13 games right
and with six pitches later the top four
in that Astros lineup I produced four
run double singles
Omer single double homer it was amazing
to see that flurry from the top of that
order so all those guys I think are in
the mix so to me that that sequence
there Dan everything you want to know
about baseball these days where the ball
is flying we have a ton of relief
pitchers in the game and a ton a whole
month it's the intersection of homeruns
or relief pitching in that one sequence
in the seventh but we're talking to Tom
Verducci Sports Illustrated Major League
Baseball on Fox but I ask you this after
Game two is the series shifted to
Houston who had momentum and here we are
with another dramatic Houston win in
game 5 is the series now shifts to LA
momentum clearly with the Astros with
Verlander on the mail yeah JV getting
the ball as Hanuman listening runs and
won every game he's fist you during
relief for starting for them I mean
they've got good at that up and down a
lineup now
very different from Game two or they you
know they rallied late in that game but
now everybody's hot everybody's
confident yeah I have to say that
momentum just because of Verlander and
you know what theme Roberts do that
before the game last night we were
talking to him at his office before the
game the Dodgers manager and he talked
about using as many pitchers and he
could and really playing the game
urgently because he had curse our
tonight
or at least gave five there and knowing
that her Lander was there in Game six he
said we have to win first I gets the
ball just like they have to win her in
Berlin two gets the ball so he's looming
out there form Tom thanks for joining us
on short notice and safe travels back to
Los Angeles that's Tom Verducci great
baseball writer from Sports Illustrated
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]